Our final answer is negative 19 plus the square root of 77. Nice work if you
found this answer. Now this one was tough because we will end up distributing a
square root of negative 11 in our problem. Let's see how it's done. First we
distribute the square root of 7 to 2 root 7 and to 3 root 11. Next we
distribute the negative square root of 11 to 2 root 7 and to 3 root 11... I
write all these out so that way you don't confuse multiplying numbers and
multiplying radicals. Like for this first term, I have 1 times 2 which equals
2, and root 7 times root 7 which is just 7. For the second term, I'll have 3
times the square root of 77. For a third term, we'll have negative 2 times the
square root of 77. And finally for our 4th term we'll have negative 3 times 11.
The square root of 11 times the square root of 11 is just 11. We combine these
two terms since they both have the square root of 77. 3 root 77 minus 2 root 77
is 1 root 77. We carry out the multiplication and then we'll have 14 minus 33,
which equals negative 19. We bring down our root to get our final answer.